Climbing is one of the things that I do that gets me closest to myself...
...where I really see my strength and my weaknesses.
Am I scared?
Am I not scared?
Do I get distracted easily?
How do I deal with pressure?
Have I done my training?
You really get to see your qualities...
...very clearly when you're on your limit.
My name is Rannveig Aamodt and I'm from Norway.
I've been climbing for 19 years and home is now Colorado.
Climbing for me is an outlet to really push myself.
And I stay interested I think because it's so complex.
It's always something you can get better at.
My goal is to be as a diverse climber as possible.
I really want to touch all types of climbing...
...on as much different types of rocks and styles as possible.
What I do think is important and what I'm gonna follow is my motivation...
...because I think all things that you achieve, big things, come from this deep motivation.
You're not always motivated about the things that you think you're gonna be.
My goal is to listen to the motivation and then follow it.